mind your decisions I'm presh tal Walker
the mobile is perfectly balanced solve
for the missing weights X Y & Z ignore
the weight of the strings and the rods
this problem is adapted from Terry
Stickles book contemporary brain teasers
pause if you'd like to give it a try and
when you're ready keep watching to learn
how to solve this problem
[Music]
the principle to solve this problem is
balancing torque suppose one side has a
distance of d1 and a mass of m1 and the
other side has d2 and m2 then m1 times
d1 has to equal m2 times D to focus on
this part of the diagram suppose the
left side has a mass of m1 then m1 times
d1 has to equal m2 times d2 we
substitute in the values for this
diagram and then solve for m1 m1 works
out to be 30 but it's not a single mass
it'll be the total mass of the entire
system that's hanging since it's the
entire mass 30 will be equal to X plus y
then we use the principle of balancing
torque 3x will be equal to 2y we solve
for y and then we substitute that into
our first equation and then we solve for
x x will be equal to 12 and we
substitute back to get Y will be equal
to 18 we've now solved the left side of
this diagram let's calculate the total
mass this is a total mass of 30 this is
15 and here is 100 we add these up to
get 145 that'll be the mass on the left
side of the system we then have 145 x 2
will be equal to z times 5 we then solve
for z and we get the answer of 58
kilograms and those are the values we
want X is equal to 12 y is equal to 18
and Z is equal to 58 kilograms this is a
fun way to teach a little bit of algebra
and physics at the same time plus it
works out to be a nice puzzle thanks for
making mind your decisions one of the
best channels on YouTube
as always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]